welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and you better check
yourself before you wreck yourself
because the brand new rick and morty is
now out season six episode two is filled
with a lot of easter eggs call backs and
hidden details throughout this video
we're going to be breaking them all down
before we talk about our thoughts on the
new entry without the way a huge thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
rick and morty season 6 episode 2.
[Music]
okay so the episode is called rick and
mort well lived and this calls all the
way back to morty night run this had
rick and morty traveling to blips and
chits which was an arcade that had
several games including roy a life well
lived this virtual reality simulation
placed morty in the shoes of roy and
with him he lived out of life as a kid
that turned into a college football
player before he went to work at a
carpet store he was diagnosed with
cancer it all seemed bleak but morty
managed to beat it he ended up returning
to work at the carpet store where he was
killed by a falling rug and rick ripped
him for being such a loser that he ended
up going back there he then tried the
game and ended up going off the grid
showing how different that the two
characters are this guy's taking roy off
the grid this guy doesn't have a social
security number for roy
the episode is also filled with lots of
movie callbacks including die hard with
summer taking on the role of john
mcclane this is pretty much name dropped
by every character and you could say
that this reference was a die-hard one
that refused to die now we discover that
aliens have attacked the arcade and this
is glitch the roy game splitting muddy's
consciousness when it restarted this
might throw you off a bit and when we
first open the episode we can hear that
every single character has morty's voice
he's classed as an npc and an npc is
also a slang term that i probably get
called a lot and it originates from the
idea that we exist in a simulated
reality with some people taking on the
role of npcs they give the exact same
opinions without critical thinking and
are programmed to just repeat things
others have said without any thoughts of
their own basically just means that
there's lots of stupid bots like my 1
million subscribers and it's clearly
making fun of morty with this meta joke
and though we get lots of die hard
references we also get an overall play
on one of the major theories floating
around about inception i've covered this
in a video before but in case you don't
know there's lots of people who think
that inception was actually an inception
on cobb himself though this was never
confirmed many suspect that the crew
were actually planting the idea into
cop's mind that he needed to return to
the real world and also his children
when you view the movie like this it
actually makes a lot of sense and
according to the theory the entire job
was centered around them planning this
idea into his mind this is very much the
same thing with rick who plays roy he's
attempting to get morty to realize that
he's in a game and we see this early on
with a character wearing the same
clothes as morty this is something that
other characters are influenced into
doing and becoming more like morty shows
they believe the truth of their world
now we see a rally flyer by roy which
points out that he's his grandson rick
wants to round up all five billion parts
of morty and this has turned some of
them into almost cult-like members even
though they're all pieces of the same
hole now we could to the outside to see
blips and chits already in the midst of
the attack at this point we get the
title sequence in the episode but i'm
gonna use this time to ask you to like
comment and subscribe because i'm an npc
now we get a look at morty's
subconscious and see the girl that we've
been following called martha comes from
a jewish family that morty has implanted
his stereotypes onto the end of these
episodes always comes with commentary by
the creative team and they discuss how
this was basically a common unorganized
religion and how this would fit into
simulation theory
the two should really contradict one
another but dan homan said that in the
end it doesn't really matter whether you
believe in religion or simulation theory
as it all just means that we're part of
some bigger scripted thing happening
with the universe rick constantly says
yeah look i feel like every time i
explain this i lose followers but this
isn't a religion but in the end it
somewhat turns out to be true because
they all follow and believe the same
thing now from here we could do summer
sneaking around and we get a scene that
introduces the big bad played by peter
dinklage this character clearly riffs on
hans gruber due to his suit and the
post-credits scene even introduces his
brother similar to what happened in die
hard 3. his first scene involves him
shooting someone in the head whilst at a
table and a similar thing happened with
hans to show how ruthless that he was in
the first ihod movie the game don't
touch me sounds off i don't know why but
i did chuckle at this a bit surgery
i don't like being touched
check the hostages now the hostages were
also a big part of die hard as well and
john's wife holly was of course amongst
them over with the mortys who watches
roy's arrival also brings his swat team
with them and wants to arrest them for
being a cult could be a comment on a
number of authorities trying to seize
cult grounds and the one that springs to
mind the most with me whenever they do
this is david koresh and also waco
koresh claimed to be a final prophet of
the davidian seventh-day adventists and
the waco siege saw a raid by the fbi
after several highly serious allegations
were levied at the cult definitely
recommend reading up on it and i can't
go into too many of the details here
without getting demonetised but i feel
like it's playing on that and let me
know below if you agree or not now we
learn the main marine ford in a generic
overseas war and this is of course
commenting on how murray views the world
he's a little bit racist but he has a
best friend that translated for him and
he finally comes around to the idea that
he's morty after realizing the truth
summer goes over the edge with one of
the aliens and this explodes into a
massive ball of goo huge shout out to
tvtrops.org for pointing out that this
is known in tv and movies as ludicrous
gibbs which is when there's an
over-the-top explosion of guts and blood
summer finds a walkie-talkie similar to
john mcclane and she also straps a gun
over a shoulder like he did in the movie
the first person that summer kills also
has a brother that goes a bit wild
similar to carl who popped up in that
movie however here he's called winslow
which is likely riffing on cole winslow
who's played by reginald val johnson
though summer hasn't seen the movie she
quickly fits into the role of it and
han's character goes off on how it's now
a stereotype the film itself also had
meta commentary like this with cowardice
discussing how jon thought that he was
roy rogers who'd come busting in and
save the day roy rogers was the one who
coined the phrase yipikaya and this of
course got taken by mcclain who changed
it to yubi kaye motherfu
summer changes this too walkie-talkie
die hard [ __ ]
and we cut back to roy a life well lived
we see that the world is slowly starting
to be infected with this idea and get
flashes of places like moscow which has
a statue of morty what i believe is the
tulum runes though it might just be
either generic aztec or mine ones the
taj mahal africa and a lot more you also
see how the quest has lasted what
appears to be decades due to the fact
that rick is aging up in royal life for
live the same thing happened with the
character and over time his appearance
became more like this as we saw in
season 2 the game is time dilation
within it meaning that it moves much
faster than the real world this is
something that was present in not only
inception but also westworld as well
with time moving faster due to computer
processing speeds being quicker than
reality we learn rick wants to travel
into space and beyond the borders of
reality which will reset the game unless
he's building his vessel rick has
brought in martha's father who's trying
to do is almost own inception and win
her back which are quite liked now
mother herself could also be based on
bugs from the matrix resurrections and
she has the same beauty spot that the
character did the entire cult is almost
like the freed minds of that movie and
there's a lot going on with it i also
love how rick and morty pretty much fit
into their usual roles with morty
following rick in the end a small pot of
morty is left in the game and over the
seasons we've seen a lot of discussion
about how morty is breaking away from
his grandfather's control this was of
course shown in evil morty as well but
it's definitely laced throughout a
number of entries i feel like this part
being left behind also signifies that
there is a part of him that will
eventually become independent and that
he will go off and do his own thing
interestingly it could also show that
the morty in the main world is going to
be fully subservient as the rug pieces
could all remain behind this is touched
upon by the president who's one of the
main world leaders that won't join them
this is a percentage morty which rick
says is insignificant but let me know
below whether you think this will take
morty's descending side out or not he
says that he realized early on that he
was in a game that he used his knowledge
in order to gain power
he just played the system and would
rather reign in hell than serve in
heaven in some further nods to die hard
we get an alien standing on a table
spouting off dialogue
this is similar to the tables seen in
the movie with a villain doing the same
thing and this gave john an opening to
kill him here his advice is not to hide
under a table which summer didn't do due
to her not actually seeing the movie you
also get the big bad reading a book
called nakatomi paradigm the tower in
the movie was of course called nakatami
plaza and says he's going to wander the
arcade and arm pretending to be a
hostage which was something that the
character did in the original movie roy
is now fully accepted the point he was
at when he died in the original muddy
game and shows the plan is almost coming
to an end martha is also aging up too
and we can see this in the extra lines
on her face they mention the snyder cut
and how eight percent of that was batman
dreaming with this playing on the
nightmare scene batman dreams also
played a big part in bvs i was wondering
whether the martha name was based on
that too i'm not do that why did you say
that name bit because it's a bit played
out now morty says he hasn't seen the
snyder cut but hey you've you've seen
batman v superman though right now the
world leaders screen also has several
rooms based on the ones in the real
world i'll never forget those three
podiums that we see the uk guys standing
in front of
constantly popping up throughout the
pandemic and because rick refuses to
tell morty that he loves him the world
evolves into a holy war with mort's
going against the rick they don't want
to go back to the world where rick
doesn't love them and want to stay
behind in the sim no matter what though
rick eventually does say he loves him
it's revealed that this is a robot decoy
and we of course have seen the character
use these throughout the entire show i
come back to summer and we get this die
hard reference you don't have to not do
things that were done in die hard you
could shoot the glass shoot the glass
shoot the glass
after realizing she hasn't left the
arcade because she has a reason to stay
we then get this scene
[Music]
too much this is a call back to this
merry christmas
and similar how hans took holly hostage
he holds the pair at gunpoint martha's
daughter decides to join rick and her
father dies longing to be a teenage boy
once more potentially similar to sado
wanting to be a young man martha goes
back to her grandfather and she says
she'll let her people go she also says
her name is martyr at this point which
has biblical roots and typically it
means the lady back with summer we hear
hans drop this line and the quarterback
as they say is toast oh my god the
quarterback is toast they do some
reverse psychology diehard stuff with
summer denying that the ending is
playing out in the exact same way
however we get the weird pronunciation
of mother car
and also the pair laughing together
summer has taped a gun to her back
though and she pulls it as rick and
morty leave the game they wake up simmer
to inception and get the upper hand
whereas carl arrived at the end once
more try and kill jon here winslow kills
horns like how the real winslow kill
call which kinda changes things up a bit
i guess showing that he does care rick
pays to have the roy game put into
storage so that mata can keep living her
life and we get a raiders of the lost
talk reference with they're being put
into a big storage hole the power's
credit scene features han's brother
getting a character to wear a sign
similar what happened to john at the
start of die hard 3. no one is attacking
him because it's a bit too generic and
the snow base itself might be a
reference to either the one from
inception or the airport from die hard
2. anyway that ends the episode and i
thought this was another banger i love
when the entries go off and do these
sort of self-contained heavily movie
referenced entries and it's nice
building on the right concept so i did
have a lot of fun with it obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on the
episode so make sure you let me know and
comment below we are in a competition
right now giving away three copies of
top gun maverick on the 15th of
september and all you have to do to be
on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the first episode which
will be linked on screen right now
you've seen that then we've got another
video just for you so yeah go check out
that as well your npc do not think to
question me
i'll see you over there you take care
peace